combat François Mitterrand HF sa tournée
en Afrique hier à Ouagadougou le
président de la République a été
accueilli au cri de bonjour tonton il
faut dire qu'il visitait avec son épouse
une garderie d'enfant Jean-Michel
Mercurey
treillis léopard pistolet à la ceinture
Thomas Sankara mène sa révolution comme
les visites officielles à coups de
slogans
l'apartheid l'impérialisme Bota et soit
une vie des mots scandés sur les pas du
président français au milieu des
portraits de bienvenue
visite de quartier pilote visite aux
enfants des crèches l'occasion pour le
capitaine Sankara de montrer à François
Mitterrand les premiers succès de sa
fougue révolutionnaire le tout ponctué
d'une touche de sympathie le papa blanc
devenant ici dans la bouche des enfants
un affectueux tonton
certes des entretiens politiques en
tête-à-tête ce sont déroulés à
Ouagadougou mais c'est surtout le
contact personnel entre les deux hommes
qui a été mis en avant et qui a pris
parfois un tour un peu surprenant
des tueurs comme Peter Botta ont eu le
droit de parcourir la France si belle
et si propre ils l'ont taché
l'ont taché de leur main et de leurs
pieds couvert de sang
et tous ceux qui leur ont permis
de poser ses actes en portant l'entière
responsabilité ici et ailleurs
aujourd'hui et toujours je suis comme
lui et ce qui pense je le dis aussi et
je trouve que dans un certain nombre de
ces jugements et là il a le tranchant
d'une belle jeunesse et de mérite d'un
chef d'État totalement des boissons
peuples et moi j'admire
ces qualités qui sont grandes mais il
tranche trop aussi il va il va plus loin
qu'il faut à mon avis qui me permettent
de lui parler du haut de mon expérience
un reproche amical surtout pour
signifier une réelle sympathie ou jeune
chef de l'État et lui souhaiter une
réussite que la France est prête à aider